ehi ehi solo del futuro e vive come
forza non ho tempo di spiegare ma cazzo
vuoi ma facciano solo
venite [ __ ] aim bella di un dio ho
chiesto e malore ma porca [ __ ] è da
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo su
there's no time to explain è un
videogame bellissimo ragazzi avete
consigliato guardato è fantastico è
inutile tanto che ve lo spiego tanto
vale giocarci perché che cosa cazzo fa a
quello stai calmo già adesso adesso
inizio stai tranquillo per l'amor di dio
o ma ragazzi veramente questo gioco ha
una trama ragazzi dall'altra ma visto
ciò che è bellissimo per me inizia che
come avete visto cesco zizzi che
dovrebbe essere meta al futuro cioè
prima che lo so perché non ho ancora
capito perché sfruttata una chiesa di
granchio gigante se lo è portato via i
ferimenti a noi dobbiamo dobbiamo
riprendere solo in poche parole
praticamente noi dobbiamo salvare me
stesso del futuro non chiedetemi perché
i ragazzi dalla trama è semplicissima ma
è fantastica io non so perché non avessi
ancora giocato con noi idee quanta ci
siamo ci siamo è fermo stronzo fermo
verna che poi ragazzi che cazzo interno
tanto explain va bè ragazzi è in poche
parole cosa fanno così tanto basta sono
vivo sono creativo non so come cazzo
fatto schivarli ma sono ancora vivo da
parte mi ricorda troppo metà slugger
ragazzi è fantastica
comunque la cosa io volevo dire che lì
ogni il mio me stesso del passato già
lasciato una sottospecie di di razzo non
so che cazzo è sta roba da me l'ha
lasciato in me stesso del del futuro
ragazzi io io lo voglio per natale a
natale sapete che regalo farmi
maledizione lo voglio assolutamente devo
allora termiche stirati mi stanno in
curando uno dietro l'altro
devo riuscire a buttarla giusto a merda
non ho neanche capito come ma ok
perfetto ci dovrei riuscire a fare di
far così si va insomma l'inizio
sai cos'è ragazzino non ho neanche
capito perché stiamo facendo questo
ok ok ok avevo ordinato un'aragosta ai
perni non un cazzo di granchio gigante
un'edizione ragazzi non chiedetemi che
cazzo è sta roba ma devo fare qualcuno
gradisce della polpa di granchio ma
perché ce n'è per tutti in abbondanza
dell'asti tu però devo allora buttare
giù sta roba come cazzo la butto giù
devo stare fermi fermi su casi adesso
vado visto ok si chi è il padrone nel
mondo di internet
i ragazzi che cazzo su c'è cos'è aiom in
più sul gol non ti caccio rivolto a soli
io sono io di prima e massei [ __ ] ma
lo sapevi che succedeva questo perché
rei di fatto
credo che debba fare il secondo raga che
non saldato di brutto per sbaglio non ha
capito che questi erano livelli avete
pazienza
salvacosta intervento o che credo che
possa fare il culo allo squalo adesso
effettivamente mai così fuori stronzo
quindi ragazzi se volete farvi trovare
un bel regalo sotto l'albero non avete
scuse non ho capito il cazzo preso ma
non me ne frega niente devo salvarmi
devo salvare meglio in futuro
inizia allora premiati e va bene che ha
mai troppo gli uffici come cazzo faccio
o che culo ragazzi io vi dico la mi do
un consiglio se per caso vi capita di
vedere voi stessi nel futuro che vi
chiedete aiuto non aiutatevi perché
finite malissimo i ragazzi fermi un
attimo che questi casi notissima ok ok
ok si grande ok cellophane perfetto per
[ __ ] morite tutto ma che è ma
passi [ __ ] tra due ragazzi dovete
spiegarmi sto tizio che cosa stava
facendo all'inizio per riuscire a jack
sock uso più
ok ragazzi senza ragazzi i personaggi
che allo ragazzi personaggi credo che
cammino di livello in livello io salgo
ogni volta me nel futuro ma ogni volta
ci sarà qualcuno in pericolo quindi dove
andarlo a salvarci permette ci sono due
12 miliardi di me è una cosa
intricatissima ogni volta che anche
qualcuno di me nel futuro muore io lo
vado a salvare cioè nel senso ci sono
due miliardi di me nel futuro in poche
parole questa è la trama è bellissimo di
tre anni trama è fantastico è proprio
bello perché non c'è una trama cioè non
si capisce un cazzo di quello che
succede ma è fantastico perché sono
troppo di vedere come cazzo finisce devo
acquisita qua come cazzo faccio pesanti
fermi lunar non ha senso devo fare ok ok
no no ogni testa maledizione che ti fai
leggermente male amico mio [ __ ] ma
allora terminati ma sì ce l'ho fatta
cazzo non si possono non ci posso credo
che ci siamo ci siamo no no che culo
assurdo che culo a su fermo stai ferma
qua qualcuno ragazzi sapete che cosa
farmi a natale non avete scuse non avete
scoperto anche detto il regalo lo voglio
voglio sta cazzo di arma a tutti i costi
e bellissima dello stato ho capito che
ti devo salvare ci sto provando cazzo
non è facile paolo tuo e buffa bomba
casole ole ole mamma mia mamma mia ok
ben fermi al prossimo livello raga devo
riuscire a farlo senza morire una volta
sarà impossibile ma ci devo provare
aspettate un attimo e vai vai vai vai
madonna mia che canestro adesso negli
occhi di tutti e tre che cazzo hanno un
aspetto questo nuovo credo c'è questo
questo avevo visto da infatti non
l'avevo visto perfetto
vai così tutte che culo assurdo
cioè io sto avendo più culo che
nell'acqua possa andarci nell'acqua
possa ancora darci che aspetto mai così
ragazzi dove devo fare il culo asso
squalo abbiate pazienza ma se non vado
avanti o che ragazzi sta cosa che si
controlla con il mouse che vi posso fare
quel che cazzo voglia e bellissimo cane
è grande così
si ok ok ok ragazzi già sto facendo
c'è la stoffa c'è dove sono sono di
sopra c'è ma io io adesso sì sì ma no ma
come cazzo 4 essere così deficiente
no ragazzi devo perfetto sono ancora 18
no non ce la farò mai raga impossibile
che devo fare devo fare così
[Musica]
il portale importanti oggi mamma ma era
difficile
vai così sfida partita ok attratto
ragazzi sto facendo malissimo a me
stesso del c'è perché per niente lo
scuola mi sta stringendo tra i denti o
misto beccando continuamente ma chi se
ne fotte
credo che devo beccarli la la pinna ma
non ne sono sicuro perché tipo
lampeggiava e così non ho mai capito
dove sta andando
fermo
sì ma massima tanto ma volete lanciarmi
qualche bomba atomica tanto ci siano e
mi fermi fermo brutto stronzo fermo
perché è uno squalo deve caricare bombe
perché l'ho battuto soprattutto stronzo
che sto facendo uscire dalla femmina ma
perché devi cagarmi le bombe in testa
preferibile cagate di piccione [ __ ]
ancora non mi puoi fare niente perché ti
massacro prima madonna ragazzi ma questo
cazzo dura ragazzi ci vediamo un bene si
ok ho vinto ho vinto così no finisca il
nuovo bellissimo ragazzo non è un gioco
è bellissimo ragazzi io voglio veramente
assurdo giocare la versione ufficiale
quando esce da una cosa è uscita ma il
sanremo è stata fantastica
ragazzi vi giuro è una trama ma è
bellissimo bibi è fantastico non so che
cazzo dire comunque ragazzi come al
solito seguito è piaciuto lasciato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non vi dotata la
descrizione seznec rischi discrete noi
ci vediamo al prossimo video ei sono
terrà al futuro deve venire con me forza